Once again, it's election season. This year, contests from governorships and Senate seats to city councils and school boards will turn on headline-grabbing issues including abortion, the economy, climate change, and education. But political and psychological research has found that most often, voter behavior is not driven by the nuances of policy debates on these topics. Instead, it's how voters feel about candidates and political parties. whom they trust to share their values and the emotions that politicians' messages, speeches, and ad campaigns evoke. So how do emotions drive our political behavior? What makes an effective political speech or ad campaign versus one that falls flat? How can small changes in wording reshape voters' opinions on controversial topics?
选举季又到了。今年，从州长和参议员席位到市议会和学校董事会，各项竞选都将围绕堕胎、经济、气候变化和教育等备受关注的议题展开。但政治和心理学研究发现，选民的行为往往并非由这些议题中政策辩论的细微差别所驱动。相反，它取决于选民对候选人和政党的感受，取决于他们信任谁能代表自己的价值观，以及政客的信息、演讲和广告宣传所激发的各种情绪。那么，情绪是如何驱动我们的政治行为的？是什么让一场政治演讲或广告宣传有效，而另一场却反响平平？措辞上的微小变化又如何重塑选民对争议性话题的看法？
And what role might political messaging play in shaping our increasingly polarized public discourse? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Drew Weston, a clinical personality and political psychologist and professor in the departments of psychology and psychiatry at Emory University. He also runs the consulting firm Weston Strategies, which advises progressive nonprofits and Democratic candidates. on how to talk with voters about a range of issues, from abortion to immigration to taxes. He's tested political messages with thousands of voters over the past two decades. He is also author of the 2008 book, The Political Brain, The Role of Emotion in Deciding the Fate of the
政治信息在塑造我们日益两极分化的公共话语中又扮演了什么角色？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。今天的嘉宾是德鲁·韦斯顿博士，他是一位临床人格心理学家和政治心理学家，也是埃默里大学心理学和精神病学系的教授。他还经营着一家名为“韦斯顿策略”的咨询公司，为进步派非营利组织和民主党候选人提供建议，指导他们如何与选民沟通从堕胎到移民再到税收等一系列议题。在过去的二十年里，他已经对数千名选民进行了政治信息测试。他还是2008年出版的《政治大脑：情绪在决定命运中的作用》一书的作者，
Nation, and he's working on a follow-up book to be published in 2023. He is a frequent contributor on political and psychological issues on radio, television, and in print, in venues such as the New York Times, the Washington Post, and CNN. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Weston. Thanks for having me again. Before I toss out my first question, I want to make clear that APA is a nonpartisan organization, so I want to be sure that our discussion is balanced and that we will talk about Democrats, Republicans, and independents without fear or favor.
目前他正在撰写一本将于2023年出版的后续著作。他经常在广播、电视和印刷媒体上就政治和心理学问题发表评论，合作媒体包括《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》和CNN。感谢您今天参加我的节目，韦斯顿博士。谢谢你的邀请。在提出第一个问题之前，我想明确一点，美国心理学会是一个无党派组织，所以我希望我们的讨论保持平衡，我们将不偏不倚地讨论民主党人、共和党人和独立人士。
How does that sound to you? I promise to be just like Fox News, fair and balanced. But I will say that you did introduce me someone who works with Democrats, and Republicans will be especially happy with what I have to say, because Republicans tend to be very good at messaging, and Democrats tend to be really awful at it. So I'll be more critical of Democrats. All right, thank you.
你觉得这样可以吗？我保证会像福克斯新闻一样，做到公平公正。但我得说，你介绍我时提到我与民主党人合作，共和党人会对我的观点感到特别高兴，因为共和党人往往非常擅长信息传递，而民主党人在这方面往往非常糟糕。所以我对民主党人的批评会更多一些。好的，谢谢。
So my first substantive question, in an article a couple of years ago called How to Win an Election, you wrote that politics is, quote, less a marketplace of ideas than a marketplace of emotions. Why is that? Why is it so crucial for politicians to reach voters on an emotional level rather than just an intellectual one? In some ways, you could answer that question by asking, how do we choose a mate? Or how do we choose a, how do we choose dinner?
那么我的第一个实质性问题是，在几年前一篇题为《如何赢得选举》的文章中，你写道，政治“与其说是一个思想市场，不如说是一个情绪市场”。为什么会这样？为什么政客们从情感层面而非仅仅从理智层面去触达选民如此关键？在某种程度上，你可以通过问“我们是如何选择伴侣的？”或者“我们是如何选择晚餐的？”来回答这个问题。
You know, we don't go through the list of like with a mate. If we do go through a list of, let's see, I'm going to make a list of pros and cons. There's 15 on this side, 15, on that side. We would typically be divorced in about two years because that's simply not how it's not how our minds work. We're, I guess another way to put it is that emotions provide the fuel for human behavior and cognition provides or thinking provides the road map. So there are two basic questions that voters ask when they try to decide on which party or candidate they support. one is, does this person understand and care about people like me? And the second is, does this person share my values? And you know what? If you're an educated voter, if you're not a terribly educated voter, those are the same two questions that you ask. And in an emotional way, they're actually pretty rational questions most of the time. So much of your work has to do with exploring the importance of language in political messaging. One example I've heard you put forward is that people react completely differently,
你知道，我们在选择伴侣时并不会列出一张清单。如果我们真的列出一张清单，看看这一边有15个优点，那一边有15个缺点，我们通常会在两年内离婚，因为这根本不是我们大脑运作的方式。我想换一种说法是，情绪为人类行为提供了燃料，而认知或思考提供了路线图。因此，选民在决定支持哪个政党或候选人时，会问两个基本问题：一是这个人是否理解并关心像我这样的人？二是这个人是否认同我的价值观？你知道吗？无论你是否受过高等教育，你问的都是这两个同样的问题。而且在情感层面上，这些问题在大多数时候其实是非常理性的。你的很多工作都与探索语言在政治信息传递中的重要性有关。我听过你提出的一个例子，人们对不同描述的反应完全不同，
to a program that's described as, say, helping the unemployed versus one that helps, quote, people who have lost their jobs. Why are these seemingly small changes in language so significant? From a neuroscience perspective, they're activating different, what you would call, and you would call this from a clinical perspective as well, different networks of associations in our minds and brains, that is, interconnected sets of thoughts and feelings and images and memories, and values so that when you activate part of that network, you activate the rest. So when you, for example, say, oh, I'm concerned about the unemployed, you're taking real people with pain lines faces who may have just had to tell their kid that they're moving and that this is, sweetie, this isn't
比如一个项目被描述为“帮助失业者”与“帮助那些失去工作的人”。为什么这些看似微小的语言变化如此重要？从神经科学的角度来看，它们激活了我们思想和大脑中不同的——你也可以从临床角度称之为——不同的联想网络，也就是相互关联的思想、感受、图像、记忆和价值观的集合，所以当你激活该网络的一部分时，你也就激活了其余部分。因此，当你例如说“我关心失业者”时，你是在把那些有着痛苦面容的真实的人，那些可能刚刚不得不告诉孩子他们要搬家，说“亲爱的，这不再是你的房间了”的人，
going to be your room anymore. That's a really evocative thing and it makes you feel something. You're turning people like that into a nameless, faceless abstraction, the unemployed, which is also an other. You know, it's like if I'm not unemployed right now, I don't, I'm thinking, well, I'm sure glad I'm not them. And as soon as you, is that themify somebody, you decrease empathy for them. So can you really flip public opinion on a question just by describing the topic in a different way? I mean, how much difference might this make in terms of poll numbers? I'll give you a couple of examples. Recently, I did a study on Southern voters looking at how to diffuse the issues of race and race baiting that were brought up by the rights attack on, quote, unquote, critical race theory, or CRT, which, of course, it's not being taught in any school. It's not, it's not taught in the vast majority of undergraduate universities. It's taught in a handful of law school classes. In fact, there's one law school class at Emory on it, and the professor asked me to guest teach on how to talk about it. So that's the extent to which our children quote are being
这是一种非常令人心酸的事情，它会让你产生某种感觉。你把这样的人变成了一个无名、无脸的抽象概念——“失业者”，这同时也是一个“他者”。你知道，如果我现在没有失业，我会想：“好吧，我很高兴我不是他们。”一旦你把某人“他者化”，你对他们的同理心就会降低。那么，仅仅通过以不同的方式描述话题，真的能改变公众舆论吗？我的意思是，这在民调数字上会有多大影响？我给你举几个例子。最近，我针对南方选民做了一项研究，探讨如何化解右翼攻击所谓“批判性种族理论”（CRT）所引发的种族和煽动种族情绪的问题，当然，这在任何学校都没有被教授。它在绝大多数本科大学里都没有教授。它只在少数法学院课程中教授。事实上，埃默里大学有一门法学院课程涉及此内容，教授还请我去做客座讲师，讲如何谈论它。所以这就是我们的孩子被
exposed to critical race thing. But what the Wright did was it was completely unethical, but very smart. And it really opened about it. They basically said, all right, how can we take anything that's being taught about race or racism in elementary and high schools, middle schools? How can we turn that into something that sounds really scary? Well, Well, let's call it critical race theory. Why? First of all, it's critical of America. Now, that's an unconscious association. They say critical. They don't say of America, but that's part of that network of associations that's activated unconsciously. So you get into there, it's critical of America, critical of white people. It's about race, and it's just a theory.
“接触”到批判性种族理论的程度。但右翼的做法完全是不道德的，却非常聪明。他们确实以此大做文章。他们基本上说：“好吧，我们怎样才能把小学、高中、初中里教授的任何关于种族或种族主义的内容，变成听起来非常可怕的东西？”嗯，让我们称之为“批判性种族理论”。为什么？首先，它“批判”美国。现在，这是一种潜意识的联想。他们说“批判”，他们没说“批判美国”，但那是潜意识中被激活的联想网络的一部分。所以你进入了那个语境：它批判美国，批判白人。它关于种族，而且它只是一个“理论”。
No facts, just a theory promulgated by those socialist, communist, people who just, hate white people and can't stand white privilege and all that kind of stuff. So that's the right side of it. Now, it turns out that you can diffuse that really, really easily, but Democrats tend to use the wrong language. They'll say, we must fight systemic racism. Well, that would be great, except that as I actually found in that particular survey, less than 20% of people, including 20% of people of color, can define critical racial. they have no idea what you're talking about. So when you talk to someone, I often say to leaders, if you're speaking to someone who's a native Spanish speaker, don't talk to them in English.
没有事实，只是一个由那些社会主义者、共产主义者、那些讨厌白人、无法忍受白人特权等等的人所宣扬的理论。这就是右翼的一面。现在，事实证明，你可以非常非常容易地化解它，但民主党人往往使用了错误的语言。他们会说：“我们必须打击系统性种族主义。”好吧，那很好，但正如我在那项特定调查中发现的那样，不到20%的人（包括20%的有色人种）能定义什么是批判性种族理论。他们根本不知道你在说什么。所以当你和某人交谈时，我经常对领导者说，如果你在和一位母语是西班牙语的人交谈，不要用英语和他们说话。
You speak to them in the language that they use. And the litmus test for me on language that I always try to tell people is, if this isn't how ordinary, normal Americans would speak about this, I don't care how you activists speak about it. But it's not ordinary voters speak about this, just don't use it. So instead of saying critical race theory, for example, or instead of saying systemic racism, if you simply describe it, if you say, hey, look, we all know that back in the 50s, when President Eisenhower was developing our interstate highway systems, if a highway was going to have to be built between one of two neighborhoods, one of them was a poor black neighborhood, and the other one was a white neighborhood, we all know which one was going to go through,
你要用他们使用的语言与他们交谈。对我来说，关于语言的试金石，我总是告诉人们：如果这不是普通、正常的美国人谈论这件事的方式，我不在乎你们这些活动家是怎么说的。如果这不是普通选民谈论这件事的方式，就不要使用它。所以，举例来说，与其说“批判性种族理论”，或者与其说“系统性种族主义”，如果你只是描述它，如果你说：“嘿，看，我们都知道在50年代，当艾森豪威尔总统开发我们的州际公路系统时，如果一条公路必须在两个社区之间修建，其中一个是贫穷的黑人社区，另一个是白人社区，我们都知道哪一个会被拆迁，”
because back then that was just seen as that was acceptable. Racism was acceptable in a way that, well, we've had some politicians who made it acceptable again, but it wasn't acceptable for about 50 years. So what you say is, look, back then, we know which way we go. And it's easy to say that that's history, but here's the problem. The problem is that 50 years later, think about the value of the houses on the two sides of that highway versus the value of the houses. in that white neighborhood.
因为在当时，这被视为是可以接受的。种族主义在当时是可以接受的，虽然我们后来有一些政客让它再次变得可以接受，但在大约50年的时间里，它是不被接受的。所以你要说的是：“看，在当时，我们知道路会怎么修。”说那是历史很容易，但问题在于：问题是50年后，想想公路两侧房子的价值与那个白人社区房子的价值相比。
The white people's houses have gone up skyrocketed in value and the people in those black neighborhoods, but they've been passing on to their kids isn't worth much at all. And then you ask, well, why don't these poor black kids have all these problems with asthma? What do you think happens when you have fumes coming off the highway? If you say that, and then you say to a white working class voter,
白人的房子价值飙升，而那些黑人社区的人，他们传给孩子的东西根本不值钱。然后你问：“为什么这些贫穷的黑人孩子会有这么多哮喘问题？”你认为当公路排放废气时会发生什么？如果你这样说，然后你对一个白人蓝领选民说，
you know, we just passed a trillion-dollar bipartisan infrastructure act, why don't we fix this? And they'll say, absolutely, that's not fair. But if you say to them that, you know, we have this problem with systemic racism, their immediate responses to get defensive. Just one more quick example like that is if you say, you know, when we teach about history, we need to teach about the history of racism because you will break even or do a little better than break even with the average voter on that.
“你知道，我们刚刚通过了一项万亿美元的两党基础设施法案，为什么我们不解决这个问题？”他们会说：“绝对的，这不公平。”但如果你对他们说“我们有系统性种族主义的问题”，他们的第一反应就是产生防御心理。再举一个类似的简短例子，如果你说：“你知道，当我们教授历史时，我们需要教授种族主义的历史”，你在普通选民那里顶多能打个平手，或者稍微好一点。
If instead you say, we need to teach about racism. the history of race and racism because, you'll kick up an extra 15 points in the polls. And the reason for that, I mean, it's a tiny change from racism to race and racism. What you've just done is you have blocked white people from getting defensive. The second you say, we need to teach you about the history of racism. Immediately, it feels accusatory if you're white. And, you know, it's not, you can understand why people. feel that way because racism, you hear it and you hear like, oh, I'm about to be attacked. Instead,
如果你换成说：“我们需要教授种族和种族主义的历史”，你在民调中会额外提升15个百分点。原因在于，这只是从“种族主义”到“种族和种族主义”的一个微小变化。你所做的就是阻止了白人产生防御心理。当你一说“我们需要教授种族主义的历史”，如果你是白人，它立刻就会让人觉得是在指责你。而且，你可以理解为什么人们会有这种感觉，因为“种族主义”这个词，你听到它时，就像是“哦，我要被攻击了”。相反，
if you say the history of race and racism, people go, well, of course we should teach about that. There's been a lot of discussion of how increasingly polarized our political landscape has become. Does that affect the way people respond to political messaging? I'm wondering if it's possible these days for a democratic politician to connect emotionally with a Republican voter or vice versa, or do people just tune out whatever comes from the other side? You know, it really depends on how far to the other side the other side is. I actually don't agree with many of my colleagues on the left who are upholsters about who they think is movable. Because who's movable depends on how you talk to them.
如果你说“种族和种族主义的历史”，人们会想：“嗯，当然我们应该教授这些。”关于我们的政治格局变得多么两极分化，已经有很多讨论了。这会影响人们对政治信息的反应吗？我想知道，如今民主党政客是否还有可能在情感上与共和党选民建立联系，反之亦然，还是说人们只是对来自另一方的任何信息都充耳不闻？你知道，这真的取决于对方离得有多远。我其实不同意我左翼同事中那些关于谁是可以争取的选民的看法。因为谁是可以争取的，取决于你如何与他们交谈。
You know, for example, on abortion, if you say, if you say to voter to say suburban independent or suburban Republican voters, or you say to even a lot of rural voters, as we learned in Kansas, where you'd get these bright red counties where 40% of people would say, no, I want the right to abortion. If in a polling question you ask people, do you believe in abortion? Well, in those suburban Republican areas, you're going to get a mix of feelings. Well, you'll get more positive than negative.
你知道，例如在堕胎问题上，如果你对选民说——比如郊区的独立选民或郊区的共和党选民，或者甚至像我们在堪萨斯州学到的那样，对许多农村选民说，在那里你会看到那些深红色的县，有40%的人会说：“不，我想要堕胎权。”如果在民调问题中你问人们：“你相信堕胎吗？”那么，在那些郊区的共和党地区，你会得到各种各样的感受。嗯，你会得到比负面更多的正面评价。
You'll get about two-thirds of Americans will say yes to that. But if you ask instead, are you pro-life or pro-choice? People have split evenly between those two things for the last 25 years until the Dobbs decision, the decision that overrode, which led the pro-choice side to go way up in the polls. Well, if you look at that, you might think, well, those are really conflicting results, right? Like two-thirds of people say that they're for abortion, four abortion rights, yet under half say they're pro-choice. Well, if instead of using language like even pro-choice, which is pretty common, pro-life suggests no matter what, I believe that from the moment of conception you're killing babies.
大约三分之二的美国人会对此说“是”。但如果你问的是：“你是支持生命权（pro-life）还是支持选择权（pro-choice）？”在过去25年里，人们在这两点上一直平分秋色，直到多布斯案裁决（推翻罗诉韦德案的裁决），这导致支持选择权的一方在民调中大幅上升。好吧，如果你看这个，你可能会想：“嗯，这些结果真的很矛盾，对吧？”比如三分之二的人说他们支持堕胎、支持堕胎权，但不到一半的人说他们支持选择权。好吧，如果不用像“支持选择权”这样相当常见的语言，“支持生命权”暗示着无论如何，我相信从受孕那一刻起你就是在杀婴。
And that's the position that the rights now taking, and it's taken a really extreme version of that position. So, you know, why is it that people reject the language of pro-choice half the time when they believe in abortion rights? It's because Democrats and progressives are offering them a position that's not equally untenable to the right, but sounds untenable, which is anytime you feel like it, you can abort. But the reality is most of us don't actually feel that way. I mean, what they feel is early on in pregnancy, when you look at what a fetus or an embryo looks like, it doesn't look anything like us. You know, for weeks, you can't tell the chicken
而这就是右翼现在采取的立场，而且它采取了该立场的一个非常极端的版本。所以，你知道，为什么人们有时会拒绝“支持选择权”这种语言，尽管他们相信堕胎权？这是因为民主党人和进步派提供给他们的立场，虽然不像右翼那样站不住脚，但听起来也站不住脚，那就是“任何时候你想堕胎都可以”。但现实是，我们大多数人其实并不那样想。我的意思是，他们的感受是，在怀孕早期，当你观察胎儿或胚胎的样子时，它看起来一点也不像我们。你知道，几周之内，你分不清鸡的
embryo whom a human embryo. That's why most of us intuitively feel like you need better and better reasons the further on that you are. You know, early on, it is clearly, it's not a question between a mother's rights and the rights of fetal tissue, because that's what it is. We don't say, oh, when's your baby coming when you're not even showing yet. We say that towards the end, though. And that says a lot about how we feel. And the point I was getting to about this is if you use language like reproductive justice, it's again one of those abstractions. First of all, no one has any idea what you're talking about.
胚胎和人类胚胎。这就是为什么我们大多数人直觉上觉得，你怀孕的时间越长，你就越需要更好的理由。在早期，这显然不是母亲的权利和胎儿组织权利之间的问题，因为事实就是如此。我们不会说：“当你还没显怀时，你的宝宝什么时候出生？”但我们会在临近分娩时那样说。这说明了很多关于我们感受的问题。我刚才要说的是，如果你使用像“生殖正义”这样的语言，它又是一个抽象概念。首先，没人知道你在说什么。
What does reproduction have to do with justice? It's like when people use words like environmental justice, I've tested that one as well, less than 10% of people can accurately define environmental justice. People go, I don't know, like, be good to this. the earth? And that's actually not what it's about. But so if you say reproductive justice, not only are you turning something that's really deeply personal and that you feel when you hear about, say, that 10-year-old girl who was raped and couldn't get an abortion in her own state, you know, Democrats should be referring to that as a moral issue. You know, there's a moral
生殖和正义有什么关系？就像人们使用“环境正义”这个词一样，我也测试过那个词，不到10%的人能准确定义环境正义。人们会说：“我不知道，就像，对地球好一点？”而这其实并不是它的含义。但如果你说“生殖正义”，你不仅把一件非常私人的事情——当你听到比如那个10岁女孩被强奸且无法在本州堕胎时，你会感同身受的事情——变成了一个抽象概念。你知道，民主党人应该把这作为一个道德问题来提及。你知道，在双方之间存在一个道德
choice between two sides. And I would urge Democrats to say, yeah, They believe that every rapist has the right to choose the mother of his child. We believe that every woman has the right to choose the father of hers. That's the difference in our moral worldviews. But see, that's a long phrase. And I'm thinking, you know, pro-choice was poll tested before it ended up in common use. And pro-life has been poll-tested. And they're both handy and short.
选择。我会敦促民主党人说：“是的，他们认为每个强奸犯都有权选择他孩子的母亲。我们认为每个女性都有权选择她孩子的父亲。”这就是我们道德世界观的区别。但你看，那是一句很长的话。而且我在想，“支持选择权”在进入常用语之前是经过民调测试的。而“支持生命权”也经过了民调测试。它们都很方便且简短。
But if pro-choice doesn't work, then what's the shorthand-allert? that will work. That's also a great question, because the left tends to have more nuanced positions on things than the right. The right will simply say, no gun, second amendment, that's their position. Or you're killing babies. I mean, that's, you know, those are the, those are the, or the free market can't interfere. There you go.
但如果“支持选择权”不起作用，那么有什么简短的替代方案能起作用呢？这也是一个很好的问题，因为左翼在事情上的立场往往比右翼更微妙。右翼只会简单地说：“不要枪支，宪法第二修正案”，这就是他们的立场。或者“你在杀婴”。我的意思是，你知道，那些是……那些是……或者“自由市场不能干预”。就是这样。
It's pretty simple. whereas it's not that easy on the left because the left is defined by having more nuanced views. So you might have to get up to a few more words, like something like this. Instead of talking about reproductive justice or pro-choice, if you say this is about the freedom to decide when and whether to have a kid. That's pretty much it. Or if you want to expand it, the freedom decide whether, when, and who'd have a child with or who'd have a family with.
这很简单。而左翼则没那么容易，因为左翼的定义就是拥有更微妙的观点。所以你可能需要多说几个词，比如这样。与其谈论“生殖正义”或“支持选择权”，如果你说“这是关于决定何时以及是否要孩子的自由”。这就差不多了。或者如果你想扩展一下，“决定是否、何时以及与谁生孩子，或与谁组建家庭的自由”。
Everyone understands exactly what that means. And if you notice when I say the freedom, I'm not only emphasizing, I'm emphasizing the value that is core to what this whole thing is about. It's not about justice. It's not really about health so much. It's first and foremost about this is about our freedom, one of the most essential freedoms we have to decide who and when when and whether to have a child. But the other thing about it is you notice I can put intonation in my voice when I say it. If I say, I'm pro-choice, no feeling in that. You could say a latter.
每个人都完全明白那是什么意思。而且如果你注意到，当我说“自由”时，我不仅在强调，我还在强调这个问题的核心价值。它不是关于正义。它其实也不是关于健康，它首先是关于——这是关于我们的自由，我们拥有的最基本的自由之一，即决定与谁、何时以及是否要孩子。但关于它的另一件事是，你注意到我说话时可以加入语调。如果我说“我支持选择权”，里面没有感情。你可以说得平淡。
You could say, I'm pro-choice. Or you could say, I'm pro-choice and I'm proud. Well, you know, actually not that many women feel like they go into an abortion clinic or to plan parenthood because they have an unwanted pregnancy. They're not going in there thinking, I'm proud. They're not necessarily thinking, I'm not proud, but they're not. thinking. It's not about pride. It's about freedom. It's about this wasn't the right time or this isn't what I wanted or this was a Tinder date for God's sake. Now, you've done work using FMRI to study people's brains while they absorb political information. And I'm just wondering, do we absorb political
你可以说“我支持选择权”。或者你可以说“我支持选择权，我为此感到自豪”。嗯，你知道，其实并没有多少女性觉得她们去堕胎诊所或计划生育协会是因为她们意外怀孕了，她们进去时会想“我感到自豪”。她们不一定在想“我不自豪”，但她们不是在想……这不是关于自豪。这是关于自由。这是关于“这不是合适的时机”或者“这不是我想要的”或者“这只是个Tinder约会，看在上帝的份上”。现在，你曾使用功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）来研究人们吸收政治信息时的大脑活动。我只是想知道，我们吸收政治
information differently from other types of information, particularly information that maybe doesn't comport with our preconceived notions. Yeah, that's a real problem. This is a, this was a design flaw built into the human brain by, if you're on the left, natural selection. If you're on the right, God messed up. And that is that, you know, we learned from Skinner, 75, 80 years ago, that people are, well, he didn't like to use feeling words, but, but, that we're essentially drawn to things that we associate with reinforcement or with positive, positive outcomes for ourselves, for our families, for the communities that we care about. And we either fight or flee things that do the opposite. That makes complete sense from an evolutionary standpoint,
信息的方式是否与其他类型的信息不同，特别是那些可能与我们先入为主的观念不符的信息？是的，那是一个真正的问题。这是一个由——如果你是左翼，那是自然选择；如果你是右翼，那是上帝搞砸了——植入人类大脑的设计缺陷。那就是，你知道，我们从斯金纳那里学到，75、80年前，人们是……好吧，他不喜欢用情感词汇，但……我们本质上被那些我们与强化或与积极结果联系在一起的事物所吸引，无论是为了我们自己、我们的家庭，还是我们关心的社区。而我们要么战斗，要么逃避那些做相反事情的事物。从进化的角度来看，这完全说得通，
an organism that didn't do that. We wouldn't be knowing that organism today. It would have gone extinct millions of years ago. The problem is that we as humans can do exactly the same thing with ideas, and that is that we are drawn towards ideas, towards beliefs that make us feel good that are reinforcing, and we repel beliefs that make us feel the opposite. So if you want to know how that actually works in the brain, we did a study back in 2004 in the election between John Kerry and George W. Bush, where we looked at the brains of strong partisans as they listened to information and we asked them to perform a reasoning task with that information about their candidate or the other candidate. And what we found was, if you looked at the, say,
一个不那样做的有机体，我们今天就不会认识它了。它在几百万年前就已经灭绝了。问题在于，我们人类可以对思想做完全相同的事情，也就是说，我们被那些让我们感觉良好、具有强化作用的思想和信念所吸引，而我们排斥那些让我们感觉相反的信念。所以如果你想知道它在大脑中是如何运作的，我们在2004年约翰·克里和乔治·W·布什的选举中做了一项研究，我们观察了强硬派选民在听取信息时的大脑，我们要求他们对关于他们候选人或对方候选人的信息执行推理任务。我们发现，如果你看，比如说，
thousand or 1,500 prior studies using neuroimaging techniques like functional neuroimaging, like fMRI, if you look at the, say, thousand studies before that of reasoning tasks, they all found activation in an area towards the top of the front of the, of the, of the brain called the dorsolateral prefrontal cortex, which is involved in conscious, rational thinking, in holding things in mind consciously so you could make decisions about them in more abstract thinking. And that's what when people reasoned, they used those circuits, which made a lot of sense. Well, we had a suspicion that in politics, when it got to be about your candidate and you had an emotional investment in your candidate, we didn't think any of those circuits were going to
一千或一千五百项先前使用神经成像技术（如功能性神经成像，如fMRI）的研究，如果你看，比如说，在那之前的一千项关于推理任务的研究，它们都发现大脑前部顶部的一个区域有激活，称为背外侧前额叶皮层，它涉及意识、理性思维，在意识中保持事物以便你可以对它们做出决定，以及更抽象的思维。这就是当人们推理时，他们使用的回路，这很有道理。好吧，我们怀疑在政治中，当涉及到你的候选人，并且你在你的候选人身上有情感投入时，我们认为那些回路根本不会
turn on at all. We expected that what was really good to happen. So here's an example. And this was a slightly altered example. So we did alter examples that they were, most of them were very close to things that the cannons actually said or done. So here's an example that was a Kerry example. It was, people are lying in the scanner. They're reading this. They're listening to this. And they're about to make a rating. And they hear the first slide comes up. It says, in 1996, John Kerry was on Meet the Press discussing Social Security, and he said, we have a generational responsibility to put everything on the table here, whether that's means testing, whether that's affecting the, changing the automatic cost of living adjustments, because we
开启。我们预料到真正会发生的是……这是一个例子。这是一个稍微修改过的例子。所以我们修改了例子，它们大多数非常接近候选人实际说过或做过的事情。所以这是一个克里的例子。它是，人们躺在扫描仪里。他们在读这个。他们在听这个。他们正要做出评价。他们听到第一张幻灯片出现。它说：“1996年，约翰·克里在《与媒体见面》节目中讨论社会保障，他说，我们有代际责任把所有东西都摆在桌面上，无论是经济状况调查，还是影响、改变自动生活成本调整，因为我们
have to make sure this program is solving for all this, you know, decades down the road. So that seems pretty reasonable. Well, then the next slide comes up, says, this year, 2004, I meet the press. John Kerry was asked about Social Security and said, we should never touch Social Security. We have a generation of responsibility to our seniors to leave it just as it has been. So then the next slide comes up and says,
必须确保这个项目在几十年后能解决所有这些问题。”所以这看起来很合理。好吧，然后下一张幻灯片出现，说：“今年，2004年，在《与媒体见面》节目中，约翰·克里被问及社会保障时说，我们永远不应该触碰社会保障。我们对老年人有代际责任，让它保持原样。”所以下一张幻灯片出现，说：
consider Mr. Carey's words and actions are inconsistent. Well, obviously they are, right? I mean, you know, 1996 says one thing, 2004, now he's playing to seniors. He says a different thing. And again, let me just stress, this is not a completely real example. It had elements of truth, but it was entirely real. So we then have them rate on a four-point scale, the extent from one, not inconsistent at all,
“考虑克里先生的言行是不一致的。”好吧，显然它们是不一致的，对吧？我的意思是，你知道，1996年说一件事，2004年，现在他在迎合老年人，他说了一件不同的事。再说一次，让我强调，这不是一个完全真实的例子。它有真实的成分，但它并不完全真实。所以我们让他们在四分量表上评分，程度从1“一点也不一致”，
to four completely inconsistent. And their finding was that Democrats had no trouble seeing the inconsistencies for George W. Bush. Evolving's had no trouble seeing the inconsistencies for John Kerry. But here's where there was a difference. The difference was when they were looking at their own candidates, we saw no activations in the reasoning circuits whatsoever. We saw what we expected, which was a bunch of first activations of emotion circuits, negative emotion circuits.
到4“完全不一致”。他们的发现是，民主党人在看待乔治·W·布什的不一致时没有困难。共和党人在看待约翰·克里的不一致时没有困难。但这就是区别所在。区别在于，当他们看着自己的候选人时，我们根本没有看到推理回路的任何激活。我们看到了我们预期的，也就是一堆情绪回路的首次激活，负面情绪回路。
They were saying, they were just pinging, pinging, pinging saying, uh-oh, this doesn't feel good. How am I going to get out of this? Then we saw activations in parts of the frontal lobes right around our eyes or between our eyes or just above our eyes, the ventrometrial prefrontal cortex, which we had hypothesized would be involved in people unconsciously regulating their motions, trying to figure out how to shut them off. And then there was a huge activation in part right behind those eyes called the anterior cingulate, which is involved in, among other things, monitoring and trying to figure out.
他们当时在说，他们只是在发出信号，说“噢，这感觉不好。我该怎么摆脱这个？”然后我们看到前额叶皮层部分有激活，就在我们眼睛周围或眼睛之间或眼睛上方，即腹内侧前额叶皮层，我们假设它涉及人们无意识地调节他们的情绪，试图弄清楚如何关闭它们。然后在那双眼睛后面有一个巨大的激活，称为前扣带回，它涉及，除其他事项外，监测和试图弄清楚
out what to do about conflict. And the prior studies that focused on cognitive conflict, we were giving emotional conflict. So all of those circuits were just wildly on. Then about 20 seconds later, they started to all turn off as people came up with rationalizations to give their can. Oh, no, not inconsistent at all. And once they did that, this was the part we did not expect.
该怎么处理冲突。而之前的研究关注的是认知冲突，我们给的是情感冲突。所以所有这些回路都在疯狂地运转。然后大约20秒后，它们开始全部关闭，因为人们想出了合理化解释来为他们的候选人辩护。“哦，不，一点也不一致。”一旦他们那样做了，这就是我们没预料到的部分。
They got bursts of dopamine in reward circuitry in the brain. And essentially, they were getting reinforced for coming to a biased conclusion. And that's the part that's scary. And it was scary back in 2004 when we did this study when, you know, we were still in the post-Watergate era where not quite, but we had moved out of it. But, you know, back in the Watergate era, Republicans were the ones who went to Richard Nixon and said, you got to resign, buddy. we just can't support you in the Senate because you obstructed justice. I mean, it seems like that was 200 years ago because you can't imagine that happening now. The problem now is that on top of that designed effect in the brain, we have a designed effect
他们在大脑的奖励回路中获得了多巴胺爆发。本质上，他们因为得出了一个有偏见的结论而得到了强化。而那才是可怕的部分。这在2004年我们做这项研究时就很可怕，当时，你知道，我们还处于后水门事件时代，虽然不完全是，但我们已经走出来了。但是，你知道，在水门事件时代，共和党人是那些去找理查德·尼克松说“你得辞职，伙计，我们不能在参议院支持你了，因为你妨碍了司法公正”的人。我的意思是，那看起来像是200年前的事了，因为你无法想象现在会发生那种事。现在的问题是，除了大脑中那个设计好的效应之外，我们还有一个设计好的效应
in the media, which is that we have now most people getting their news from social media, and they're getting it from sources that have no fact-checking and who are largely the sources who are sending them information because they're like-minded. So now we don't even share similar facts, let alone have to reason about facts in ways that are differently. You started out as a personality in clinical psychologist, and you still do academic research in those areas. But what made you turn your attention to politics and how do those two parts of your career
在媒体中，那就是我们现在大多数人从社交媒体获取新闻，而他们获取新闻的来源没有事实核查，而且很大程度上是那些给他们发送信息的来源，因为他们志同道合。所以现在我们甚至不共享相似的事实，更不用说以不同的方式对事实进行推理了。你最初是一名人格和临床心理学家，并且你仍然在这些领域进行学术研究。但是什么让你把注意力转向政治，这两个职业生涯的部分是如何
fit together? It's a really funny story. It started at first during the Clinton impeachment trials. And it's really struck by the fact that, you know, you'd have all of these commentators coming on television from the right and from the left. They would be marshalling, quote, unquote, evidence. You know, they'd be talking about facts. They'd be talking about, well, what did Hamilton and Adam's mean when they were, you know,
结合在一起的？这是一个非常有趣的故事。它最初始于克林顿弹劾审判期间。我真的被这样一个事实所震撼：你知道，你会看到所有这些评论员从右翼和左翼出现在电视上。他们会列举，所谓的“证据”。你知道，他们会谈论事实。他们会谈论，嗯，汉密尔顿和亚当斯在他们
when they were crafting this language on impeachment and the Constitution, et cetera. And they're talking about that, and they're talking about the facts of what happened with Lewinsky, what didn't happen with Lewinsky, et cetera. and they all seemed to come down on the side of what they wanted to believe in the first place. It was clear that the facts were making no difference whatsoever. So I actually started doing a little bit of research back then, and I found that there were actually three predictors of how people, how people, which side people came down on pro-impeachment or against impeachment.
制定关于弹劾和宪法的语言时是什么意思，等等。他们在谈论那个，他们在谈论莱温斯基事件中发生了什么、没发生什么的事实，等等。而他们似乎都得出了他们最初想要相信的结论。很明显，事实根本没有产生任何影响。所以我当时确实开始做了一点研究，我发现其实有三个预测因素可以预测人们，人们，哪一方的人们得出了什么结论——支持弹劾还是反对弹劾。
One was their feelings towards the parties. That was primary. Second, it was their feelings towards Bill Clinton. There were Democrats who didn't like him and they were Republicans who did. And then the third was their feelings about feminism. And if they had very strong feelings about feminism, they were more likely even beyond their feelings of Bill Clinton to believe that this was an impeachable offense.
一个是他们对政党的感受。那是主要的。第二，是他们对比尔·克林顿的感受。有不喜欢他的民主党人，也有喜欢他的共和党人。然后第三个是他们对女权主义的感受。如果他们对女权主义有非常强烈的感受，他们更有可能——甚至超过他们对比尔·克林顿的感受——相信这是一个可弹劾的罪行。
And the point of it all was when you got down to their knowledge of the facts about either the Constitution or about what had happened that had led to this, you know, what had Clinton done or not done, the facts predicted 1% of the variance in people's voting, and the rest was controlled by people's emotional reactions to the parties, to Bill Clinton, and to feminism. And so what that led me to think was, wait a minute, and it actually, it predicted eight out of the nine judges on the, justices on the Supreme Court, and how they voted in Bush v. Gore. The only one who is unpredictable, who frankly has been my favorite justice in my lifetime was David Souter. And I say that not because I've agreed with this politics, it's because I never knew which way he was going to come down.
而这一切的重点是，当你深入了解他们对宪法或导致这一结果的事件的事实知识时，你知道，克林顿做了什么或没做什么，事实预测了人们投票中1%的差异，而其余部分则由人们对政党、对比尔·克林顿和对女权主义的情感反应所控制。所以这让我想到，等一下，而且它实际上预测了最高法院九位大法官中的八位在布什诉戈尔案中是如何投票的。唯一一个不可预测的，坦率地说是我一生中最喜欢的法官，是戴维·苏特。我这么说不是因为我同意他的政治观点，而是因为我从来不知道他会站在哪一边。
Because he seemed like, you know, he was a justice who did what he was supposed to do. Justice. You know, look at the facts of the case. Don't start out with your own values, your own preconceptions, your own politics, but just look at the facts of the case. Actually, on this line, I really have to tip this way. I really have to sit that way. But the thing that was really that kicked me over from being a mild-mannered clinical psychology professor to being an ill-mannered political consultant was watching first gore throw an election in 2000
因为他看起来像，你知道，他是一位做他该做之事的法官。正义。你知道，看看案件的事实。不要从你自己的价值观、你自己的先入之见、你自己的政治开始，而只是看看案件的事实。实际上，在这一行，我真的必须倾向这边。我真的必须倾向那边。但真正让我从一个温文尔雅的临床心理学教授变成一个粗鲁的政治顾问的事情，是看着戈尔在2000年输掉选举
by speaking like a Democrat, listing his 10-point plans, not speaking enough about his values, he's never speaking about the one thing that his consultants told him not to speak about, which was typical democratic consulting. Don't talk about what matters to you because it's not high in the polls. And that was energy and climate. Imagine if Al Gore had gone to Florida. And he had given speeches on the coast of Florida. And he had said, look, there are a lot of you who are parents and girls.
通过像民主党人那样说话，列出他的10点计划，没有足够多地谈论他的价值观，他从来没有谈论过他的顾问告诉他不要谈论的一件事，那就是典型的民主党咨询。不要谈论对你重要的事情，因为它在民调中不高。那就是能源和气候。想象一下，如果阿尔·戈尔去了佛罗里达。他在佛罗里达海岸发表了演讲。他说：“看，你们中有很多是父母和祖父母，
grandparents and who worked really hard for this land that we're standing on right now that you want to pass on to your kids and grandkids. You know, I know a lot of you are not sure whether or not there's anything to this idea about climate change. I understand it, although it's kind of a lot like what we saw when the tobacco, quote unquote, scientists in their white coats were saying, oh, you can bring this black, this black soot into your nose. Don't worry about it's not going to do anything to you. It's kind of like these, hear these people say, and white coats for the oil company saying, oh yeah, you can breathe this pollution into your nose,
你们为我们现在站立的这片土地辛勤工作，你们想把它传给你们的孩子和孙子。你知道，我知道你们很多人不确定关于气候变化这个想法是否有什么依据。我理解，尽管它有点像我们在烟草公司所谓的‘科学家’穿着白大褂说‘哦，你可以把这种黑色的煤烟吸进你的鼻子，别担心，它不会对你做任何事’时看到的情况。这有点像这些人说，听这些穿着白大褂为石油公司工作的人说，‘哦，是的，你可以把这种污染吸进你的鼻子，
won't bother you there, and then it goes up into the air, and there's trillions of tons of it up there. Don't worry, it won't affect the earth. It won't affect the atmosphere. But even if you don't believe any of that, even if you don't believe what the vast majority of scientists now do believe, do you want to gamble with the land and the homes
它不会打扰你，然后它上升到空气中，那里有数万亿吨的污染。别担心，它不会影响地球。它不会影响大气层。’但即使你不相信任何这些，即使你不相信绝大多数科学家现在所相信的，你想拿你们辛勤工作留给孩子和孙子的土地和家园去赌博吗？
that you have worked so hard to leave for your kids and grandchildren, do you really want to do that? It's not a gamble I'd want to make because I could be wrong about this, but you know, people on the other side could be wrong about this too. And if they are, you're not going to be leaving anything to your grandchildren. Now, he lost by 500 votes. In Florida, imagine it. In Florida, yeah, if he had done that in Florida. Yeah.
你们真的想那样做吗？这不是我想做的赌博，因为我可能在这件事上错了，但你知道，对方的人也可能在这件事上错了。如果他们错了，你就不会给你的孙子留下任何东西。”现在，他以500票之差输了。在佛罗里达，想象一下。在佛罗里达，是的，如果他在佛罗里达那样做了。是的。
So just to wrap up, you wrote your book, The Political Brain 15 years ago, and a lot has happened since then. And you're working on a follow-up book. So can you give us a little bit? preview of what might be in the next book? Yeah, I sure can. It's based on, you know, when I wrote the last book, I'm being totally honest here. I had no idea before the before and when the reviews came out, whether they were going to come out saying, this guy's a total fraud.
所以最后总结一下，你在15年前写了你的书《政治大脑》，从那时起发生了很多事情。你正在写一本后续的书。所以你能给我们一点关于下一本书可能包含的内容的预告吗？是的，我当然可以。它是基于，你知道，当我写上一本书时，我在这里说的是实话。在评论出来之前，我根本不知道他们会出来说“这家伙是个彻头彻尾的骗子”。
He's a, he's a psychologist who's, yeah, he's done a bunch of reading on elections. He's gone back and I had an editor who made me go all the way back to. FDR and to study his convention addresses all the way on up. But I hadn't done any work in practical politics before. I'd never get a speech to a political audience. I might have given one academic talk at a political psychology conference once. I don't even think I'd done that by that point. So, so, you know, I'm thinking, I have no idea how this is going to be received, because it was advancing what at that time was, believe it or not, you're going to laugh, was a radical thesis. Then emotions are central to politics.
他是一位心理学家，是的，他阅读了大量关于选举的书籍。他回溯了历史，我的一位编辑曾让我一直追溯到富兰克林·罗斯福（FDR），去研究他所有的竞选演说。但我之前从未从事过实际政治工作。我从未对政治听众发表过演讲。我可能曾在一次政治心理学会议上做过一次学术报告。我甚至认为在那之前我连那次都没做过。所以，你知道，我在想，我不知道这会受到怎样的反响，因为它在当时——信不信由你，你会笑的——提出了一个激进的论点：情感是政治的核心。
at that time, Democrats were all running on this. All they were being taught was, and they were running on campaigns on the idea that a campaign is a debate on the issues. So what you want to do is you want to spell out where you are on the issues and your 10-point plan on every one of them. And, you know, the thesis of my book was, actually, no one wants to see your fact election. That's not what they're interested in. And if you look at the history of elections, that's not how people vote at all. If you look at Barack Obama versus Hillary Clinton, I don't think they differed on anything in their politics, in their policies,
在那个时候，民主党人都在以此为竞选纲领。他们所受的教育以及他们开展竞选活动所依据的理念是：竞选就是一场关于议题的辩论。所以你想做的是阐明你在这些议题上的立场，以及你在每一个议题上的十点计划。你知道，我那本书的论点是，实际上，没人想看你的事实选举。那不是他们感兴趣的。如果你看看选举历史，人们根本不是那样投票的。如果你看看巴拉克·奥巴马和希拉里·克林顿，我不认为他们在政治主张或政策上有任何分歧，
but they ran really different campaigns, say, in 2007, 2008, where he could speak to people emotionally, talking about the same issues, and she just had a much harder time, much harder time doing it to the average person to speak to that emotional way. Anyway, the book was advancing the quote of a radical thesis that not only was that democratic strategy wrong, but so were political scientists models, which were virtually all rational choice models at that point. You know, oh, let's see, I weigh abortion this percent, I weigh the economy this percent, I weigh immigration this percent. And, you know, I have this whole list of 25 issues that I'm keeping in my mind and I'm weighing. How much do I like them and how much do I like each candidate party's position, each one?
但他们在2007年、2008年的竞选方式却截然不同。他能以情感方式与人们交流，谈论同样的议题，而她却很难做到这一点，很难以那种情感方式与普通人交流。总之，这本书提出了一个所谓的激进论点，不仅民主党的策略是错误的，政治学家的模型也是错误的，当时这些模型几乎全是理性选择模型。你知道，哦，让我看看，我给堕胎权打这个百分比，给经济打这个百分比，给移民打这个百分比。然后，你知道，我脑子里有一份25个议题的清单，我正在权衡。我有多喜欢他们，以及我有多喜欢每个候选人政党的立场，每一个都是？
Well, you know, in psychology, we call that doing multivariate statistics, and it requires really, really well-worked-out statistical programs and software. And it involves hundreds of thousands or millions of split-second calculations that our brains cannot do. Most of us cannot do multivariate statistics in our heads. So what do we do? We simplify the equation by asking those two questions. Does this person understand, care about people like me? And does this person share my values? So that's where I was coming from at the time.
嗯，你知道，在心理学中，我们称之为进行多元统计，它需要非常、非常完善的统计程序和软件。它涉及成千上万甚至数百万次我们大脑无法完成的瞬间计算。我们大多数人无法在脑海中进行多元统计。那么我们该怎么办？我们通过问那两个问题来简化等式：这个人理解并关心像我这样的人吗？这个人认同我的价值观吗？所以这就是我当时的想法。
I had no idea how the political community could receive it. And I also really wasn't entirely sure I wasn't a fraud. And then I actually got a call about two weeks after the book came out from this person called. This person says, is this Dr. West? Yes, and I'm in a Starbucks in my sweats in Atlanta. It says, would you hold for President Clinton? And this was 2007. And I think, yeah, and I'll hold for Mahatma Gandhi too.
我不知道政治界会如何接受它。而且我真的不太确定自己是不是个骗子。然后，在书出版大约两周后，我接到了一个电话。对方说，是韦斯特博士吗？是的，我当时在亚特兰大的星巴克，穿着运动服。对方说，请为克林顿总统保持通话。那是2007年。我想，是啊，我也愿意为圣雄甘地保持通话。
And maybe Martin Luther King while we're at it. But I didn't say that, but that's what I was thinking. But then next thing you know what this voice comes on is Hill Clinton. And saying, you know, I'm in Iowa right now with Hillary, and we're, you know, we're doing stops where she's campaigning. And I'm reading her, reading her your book and reading her passages from it that I think are particularly useful for. And he said, you know, those things that you said Al Gore should have said in his debate against George W. Bush, said, that stuff was spot on. And I thought, all right, if this guy's saying this, maybe I'm not completely fraught. You know, in clinical work, you're doing the same thing.
也许再加上马丁·路德·金。但我没说出口，但我心里是这么想的。但接下来你知道，那个声音变成了比尔·克林顿。他说，你知道，我现在在爱荷华州和希拉里在一起，我们正在进行竞选停留。我正在读你的书，并向她朗读我认为特别有用的段落。他说，你知道，你说的那些阿尔·戈尔在与乔治·W·布什辩论时应该说的话，他说，那些话非常到位。我想，好吧，如果这家伙这么说，也许我不是完全在骗人。你知道，在临床工作中，你也在做同样的事情。
You're kind of threading the needle. Someone's got a conflict about something. You're trying to figure out, how do I talk with this person about this in a way? Won't make them defensive, but will allow them to consider possibilities that they might not have considered before and consider changing in one way or another. Well, you know, and what I realized was when I started to do political consulting, I was doing psychotherapy with 60 million people at a time. The skills were really not all that different. The only thing that was different was that I wanted to make sure that if I generated, say, nine different ways of talking about an issue, whether it was back then the Iraq war, whether it was immigration, whether it was trade policy, whether it was taxes, whether it was how do we help working people, whether it was abortion. And most of these issues, by the way, has really stayed the same since I started working on this stuff.
你就像是在穿针引线。某人对某事有冲突。你试图弄清楚，我该如何以一种方式与这个人谈论这件事？不会让他们产生防御心理，但会让他们考虑以前可能没考虑过的可能性，并考虑以某种方式做出改变。嗯，你知道，我意识到当我开始做政治咨询时，我是在同时为6000万人做心理治疗。这些技能其实并没有什么不同。唯一不同的是，我想要确保如果我生成了，比如说，九种谈论议题的不同方式，无论是当时的伊拉克战争、移民、贸易政策、税收、如何帮助劳动人民，还是堕胎。顺便说一句，自从我开始研究这些东西以来，大多数这些议题确实保持不变。
of 15 years ago. I didn't want to just do this by the seat of my pants. I wanted to test those messages against each other and against the absolute toughest message I could write from the other side. So what I said was, yeah, I'll do this, but only if I can do the quantitative work along with it, which at first meant working with pollsters and then I eventually started doing that myself. But this is a long-wind of way of saying that what I often told people when they He said, well, that's going to be a lot more expensive to do all that polling along with us. I said, yeah, but I said, you know, the best antidote to narcissism and especially male narcissism is empiricism. You can think you have the greatest ideas of how to talk about this thing.
15年前。我不想只是凭感觉行事。我想用这些信息相互测试，并用我能写出的来自对方阵营的最强硬的信息进行测试。所以我说，好吧，我会做，但前提是我可以同时进行定量研究，起初这意味着与民调专家合作，后来我最终开始自己做这件事。但这话说来话长，我经常告诉人们，当他们说，嗯，做所有这些民调会贵得多。我说，是的，但我说，你知道，克服自恋，尤其是男性自恋的最好解药是经验主义。你可能认为你有关于如何谈论这件事的最伟大的想法。
And then you test them and you learn that, well, that one beat the opposition. But there was another message that I didn't realize was going to do even better. let's go with that one. Or let's offer people several messages that they could use because they're actually all beating the opposition. But, you know, I'd catch all kinds of words and phrases that I was using that I thought, oh, geez, how did I make that stupid error? Well, I learned that I made the stupid error by testing it. So in the meantime, since the political brain came out 15 years ago, I've tested about a million messages with over 100,000 voters. And so this textbook is going to have the benefit of not only the background in psychology and neuroscience,
然后你测试它们，发现，嗯，那个击败了对手。但还有另一个我没意识到会表现得更好的信息。让我们用那个吧。或者让我们为人们提供几种他们可以使用的信息，因为它们实际上都击败了对手。但是，你知道，我会捕捉到我使用的各种词汇和短语，我想，哦，天哪，我怎么犯了那个愚蠢的错误？嗯，我通过测试学会了我犯了那个愚蠢的错误。所以在此期间，自从15年前《政治大脑》出版以来，我已经用超过10万名选民测试了大约100万条信息。所以这本教科书将不仅受益于心理学和神经科学的背景，
but having actually tested these things in real politics with real voters in focus groups, in online testing, in regular opinion polls by telephone surveys, you know, with thousands of voters. So I actually now can tell you, you know, there's an old adage in advertising, which is that half of our advertising dollars are a complete waste of money. and the other half work. The problem is we don't know which or which. And I'm now at the point having done this that I'm up to about 75, 80 percent getting it right, but that still means I'm 25, 20, 25 percent getting it wrong. And if I want to work for nonprofits or for a party or for a candidate in the U.S. or somewhere else whose values I share, I want to do the best possible job
而且实际上是在现实政治中，与真实选民在焦点小组、在线测试、常规电话民意调查中，你知道，与数千名选民一起测试过这些东西。所以我现在实际上可以告诉你，你知道，广告界有一句老话，就是我们一半的广告费完全是浪费钱，而另一半有效。问题是我们不知道哪一半是哪一半。我现在已经做到了这一点，我大约有75%到80%的准确率，但这仍然意味着我有20%到25%的错误率。如果我想为非营利组织、政党或美国或其他地方我认同其价值观的候选人工作，我想尽我所能做好工作，
for them I can rather than just assuming that because I thought it, it must be right. So is this book going to give away all your trade secrets then? It's going to give away a lot of them. And just to get, I will give a plug now. This is a nonpartisan podcast. I will get a plug for someone on the other side who he and I were often pitted against each other on issue after issue where he was doing the right wing side of things of how's best to talk about this.
而不是仅仅因为我这么想，就认为它一定是正确的。那么这本书会泄露你所有的商业秘密吗？它会泄露很多。为了得到，我现在要打个广告。这是一个无党派播客。我要为对方阵营的人打个广告，我和他经常在各种议题上针锋相对，他在做右翼那一套关于如何谈论这件事的最佳方式。
And I was doing it on the left, or at least from center left to left. And that's Frank Lutz, who was Newt Gingrich's brilliant word smith. I really like Frank, but I didn't like the work that he did because I didn't like the values behind it. But Frank is as good as you get at this. I taught a course of Demery for many years a seminar called the Psychology of Political Persuasion in American Electoral Politics. And I always assigned Frank's book because he's got a book called Words That Work. It's just absolutely brilliant and describes a lot of these similar kind of principles. I remember when I eventually read it, I hadn't read it until after mine came out.
而我在做左翼，或者至少是从中左翼到左翼。那就是弗兰克·伦茨，他是纽特·金里奇的天才词汇大师。我真的很喜欢弗兰克，但我并不喜欢他所做的工作，因为我不喜欢其背后的价值观。但弗兰克在这方面做得非常好。我多年来在埃默里大学教授一门研讨课，名为《美国选举政治中的政治说服心理学》。我总是指定弗兰克的书，因为他有一本名为《有效的词汇》的书。它绝对精彩，描述了许多类似的原则。我记得我最终读它的时候，是在我的书出版之后才读的。
They came out at pretty similar times. But I remember reading and thinking, wow, he's really let out all the secrets from the right. But, you know, my attitude on that is kind of, as opposed to let's just have a competition of ideas and the marketplace of ideas. Why don't we have both sides present their ideas in the most emotionally compelling ways possible so that voters really know what they're looking at, so that they really know, you know, there are one out of every 50 women is having a pregnancy where the embryo. is implanting outside her uterus, an ectopic pregnancy, that fetus or that embryo is going to die, no matter what. So the idea that now doctors are afraid to take dead fetal tissue out of a woman's body that could cause sepsis and kill her, where they could lead her to be infertile. And the other side's calling that a culture of life, you know, to me, that's how you
它们出版的时间差不多。但我记得读的时候心想，哇，他真的把右翼的秘密都泄露出来了。但是，你知道，我对此的态度是，与其进行思想竞争和思想市场，为什么我们不让双方以最引人入胜的情感方式呈现他们的想法，以便选民真正知道他们在看什么，以便他们真正知道，你知道，每50个女性中就有一个怀孕，胚胎植入在子宫外，即宫外孕，无论如何，那个胎儿或胚胎都会死亡。所以，现在医生们害怕从女性体内取出死胎组织，这可能会导致败血症并杀死她，或者可能导致她不孕，而另一方称之为生命文化，你知道，对我来说，这就是你
you talk about it. And voters should hear it in that form, not the sanitized form of, you know, some people believe that we should have choice. Some believe that we should be pro-life. Do you strongly agree, agree, disagree? That's how pollsters ask these questions, and it's not how they play out. And frankly, it's not how politicians speak about them. And I don't think it's how politicians ought to speak about it. I think they should speak in the most emotionally compelling ways about things that they believe are true that fit their values and that there's good evidence that they are true. And then let the chips fall. Well, Dr. Weston, I really appreciate you joining me today. This has been a fascinating conversation. Thank you so much. Thanks for
谈论它的方式。选民应该以这种形式听到它，而不是那种经过消毒的形式，你知道，有些人认为我们应该有选择权。有些人认为我们应该支持生命。你强烈同意、同意、不同意吗？民调专家就是这样问这些问题的，但这并不是它们表现出来的方式。坦率地说，政客们也不是这样谈论它们的。我不认为政客们应该这样谈论它。我认为他们应该以最引人入胜的情感方式谈论他们认为真实、符合他们价值观且有充分证据证明其真实的事情。然后让结果顺其自然。好吧，韦斯特博士，我非常感谢您今天加入我。这是一次引人入胜的谈话。非常感谢。谢谢你
having me on. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeckycology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you're have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyen. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
邀请我。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您有对未来播客的评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Kondyen。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。